the problem is that any piece that
involves exchanging land for ceasefire
or land for peace is politically fatal
for zielinski or did any Ukrainian
leader we can debate whether you know
the the ethics of that
um you know of of whether Crimea and
parts of the donbass should be given
away but clearly that leaves a very
major moral hazard it rewards aggression
it leaves Putin a kind the capacity to
declare some kind of Victory I mean a
hollow victory victory that's certainly
true so there's a huge moral hazard
there but the problem is that when if it
comes to the alternative to a land for
peace deal is a sort of Forever War
and if a Forever War is going to be
fought on the money on the resources um
on The Guns of the West
and um there are also questions about
the solidity of the Western Alliance I
think there are cracks that are going to
appear and I think cracks are that are
going to widen unfortunately as the war
drags on